let's bring in Mel Kiper jr. draft
expert with the mothership was in
Indianapolis at the combine and you can
tweet him at Mel Kiper ESPN Mel how are
you well I got a couple things to start
with first of all if you didn't do this
job what would you be doing wow that's a
great question Dan I didn't do this what
would I be doing well I had a chance
back in 1983 to go to work for the
Baltimore home so that didn't work out
because the Colts were moving and Ernie
of course he was gonna bring me in was
going to be leaving so had that not
happened the way it did I would have
been in the NFL and never at ESPN
because I went to I got the call to go
up an interview for the ESPN Draft job
five months later so that would have
never happened at Ernie of course he not
had my best interest at heart at that
time would have never been at ESPN right
who knows what would have happened dan
so initially I would have been in the
NFL had things going the way it was
supposed to go okay
then the ESPN call came so then the rest
of the sister we said none of that would
have happened I thought I was grew up as
wanting to be get into meteorology be a
meteorologist so I always loved the
weather and the study of the weather so
I would have thought at the time then as
a young kid meteorology would have been
my feel you have weather caster here and
that's important it looks great over the
first combine you've ever been to is
that right
yes yes first year we were allowed into
the combine where we were allowed total
access inter I should say access in
general in the watch it and it was it
was a nice experience to be in there you
see it and obviously you get all the
numbers so we always had access that way
in terms of getting everything we needed
which were the actual printouts of the
numbers and knowing everything and our
vertical jumps to broad jumps the
three-count
all that stuff we had but to be in there
and watch it we were able to interview
you know Andy Reid Jerry Jones came over
to the set a lot of the individuals were
there around and you could talk to
people so it was good from that
standpoint to watch it live was good so
it was a productive I think weekend
Indianapolis how much do you rely on
other people's information when you
formulate your opinions with your draft
board and how much is it just you
the opinions of the ratings are just
made the mock draft is always that's
always been the misnomer damn because
well yeah
you realize on this yeah yeah that's all
I do is watch football year and you
start back in August with the big board
that's based on their why has a board
back in then because what we do and I
put that together all your updated every
every other weeks every two weeks it's
updated based on the way kids are
playing right about a one-eighth
espn.com every week so that's the rate
all the ratings you see then have
nothing to do with way the NFL is
thinking things are gonna go the mock
giraffe or always trying to figure out
what you're hearing things like that and
so the mock draft is more it's useful
for that purpose for the mock dress
information not for the ratings the
ratings have nothing to do with which
you're told by NFL people because that's
their opinion your opinion will differ
now if you have a 5th rounder that
that's you're seeing something you're
not seeing what they what they're saying
you go back to the drawing board and say
boy I missed that okay I didn't know
that that was so then you can adjust
things based on their the experts they
have more information than anybody they
know everything medical they have they
have access to more than we do so you
have to adjust somewhat if you're way
off but other than that then no I the
mock dress is the only reason why I
would talk to them about that type of
thing ten years ago how would you assess
Dewayne Haskins and how would you assess
Cuyler Murray ten years ago Cuyler
Murray would have been a probably a slot
receiver or just a you know a fifth
round draft pick fourth round draft pick
maybe if it was ten years think about
seven years ago Dan Russell Wilson was
five ten and a half and 205 210 pounds
around a four or five forty and had a
great career at both NC State and
Wisconsin was the 75th pick the third
round draft choice that was seven years
ago you fast forward to today and Kyler
Murray's in line maybe be the number one
pick overall so I said over the weekend
that you know Kyler murió was a call-up
thanks to Russell Wilson because that
was the test case we set it then Dan now
say it again now Russell Wilson was the
test case for quarterbacks not six-foot
because Michael Vick was six six foot
drew Brees was six foot Baker Mayfield
6-2 had six foot courts we've never had
this
we're a successful quarterback now go
back to Fran Tarkenton days is different
flirty never had a chance to be drafted
he went into the USFL prematurely but
the Russell Wilson opened the door for
Kyler Murray to be the number one pick
overall if you ran the Cardinals
dot-dot-dot what would you do yeah I
think they have to take Tyler Murray and
trade Josh Rose and I said Josh Rosen
doesn't sit 90 Josh Rosen to me would be
the number one quarterback in this draft
if he were in this draft okay he would
be the number one quarterback so say
what you want about Josh Rosen he had a
decent you're considering he had nothing
to work with and in Arizona the worst
offensive line in the NFL and to me if
you're the Giants if you're the Dolphins
if you're the Redskins I've heard people
say second third-round pick four rows I
don't know what they're thinking is I'm
a team I'm given a first-round pick up
for Josh Rosen if that if he's available
and I don't know if it'll be available
about this you heard Steve Times say for
now he's our quarterback whatever
Kliff Kingsbury being the coach is a
dynamic Dan that allows Kyler Murray to
be in play at number one he fits what
they're gonna do with those gonna do the
max protect that you need a quarterback
this mobile you're behind the line it
should be a little better Jimmy worse
allege that was the worst offensive line
in the league so you can't have rosin
rosin doesn't fit Kingsbury Tyler Murray
does they have the number one pick and
think it back mid first round pick by
trading Josh rose and then they're on
their way to helping that football team
so I would take if I were then based on
the Kings Barry factor I would take and
also the fact that Steve times when we
talk to people they say hey Steve time
didn't have for Josh Rosen is number one
quarterback or maybe even the number two
quarterback Josh Allen was evidently
their number one that's when your
explores true or not it's debatable but
that's what you hear so I would think
Kyler Murray would make sense there at
number one I've been saying all along
I'm on the Kyler Murray bandwagon
it's it's a new era with quarterbacks
and how they're protected and you know
how you utilize them but I also have to
look at this if I'm the Cardinals and
yes I did watch Cardinal football games
last year and you're right that's one of
the worst offensive lines I've seen in
recent memory and Josh Rosen really
didn't have a chance to shine but if I'm
Arizona don't I at least kick the tires
on the Raiders doing something stupid
and going
and giving you a couple of first-round
draft picks maybe you get three
first-round draft picks for the
opportunity to go up to number one or
two and then you get their fourth pick
overall doesn't that make more sense for
the Cardinals were skyler murray that
good you can't pass up on him well
that's what they have to determine and I
understand about the China Gruden factor
with Kyler Murray he was the one that
loved Russell Wilson of course he has
but he has there a car that's the thing
there Derrick cards a couple years ago
as you know Dan as well as anybody is an
almost NVP guy he was an MVP guy and he
can throw the was a notion he just has
think and dunked well you got to be
thinking dunk when you have known
offensive line is struggling with
injuries along the interior to rookie
tackles one of which was from North
Carolina A&T the other which Colt Noah's
gonna be good but he played injured most
of the year and the receivers were
traded away your main entity so wouldn't
you expect Derrick Carter did we had to
get the bot of his hand
okay he had no choice he can throw the
ball down the field extend things he's
got a big arm so I think Derrick are
moving forward looks like he'll be the
Ranger quarterback but if that was
offered fine you listen but if you're
number one in your Arizona that's what
you have to think about how is this
offense going to be better with Josh
Rosen or is it going to be better with
Kyler Murray it seems like you heard
Kingsbury's comments about Murray when
he was a Texas Tech but I think now it
all gets down to who is best it's all
about system it's all about fit then in
sports you know that teams go to it's
all about supporting but more fit system
fit who does that the best and that
would be Kyler Murray oh and that's no
criticism of Josh Rosen Josh Rosen with
those teams I mentioned would be better
I think
interesting any quarterback in this
draft Murray goes one so if you're if
you're Miami Washington which rather
have Trulock
daniel Jones lock from Missouri Jones
from Duke or would you rather have Josh
Rosen Todd's that one Josh Rosen by a
mile yeah I would too we're talking to
Mel Kiper the ESPN draft expert Tom
Brady told me it was a few years ago if
he had gone in the first round he'd
probably be out of the league that he
he's sort of needed to absorb a system
and you know it just worked out yeah the
injury to Drew Bledsoe looking back do
you remember what you even thought of
Brady and gentlemen do you believe that
if he had gone in the first round he
would have he would have been out of the
league by now
well what Tom said I think a lot of
quarterbacks have echoed those same
sentiments what if Dan Marino instead of
going to Miami would go into the Detroit
Lions as they pick 13 whatever it was
that year or in a little earlier in the
draft where Todd Blackledge went to
Kansas City who knows what would have
happened yeah as we always say the
history would have been rewritten if
certain things didn't fall into place
you know if Drew Brees I just say goes
to Miami instead of Dante Culpepper Nick
Saban's never coaching Alabama they
don't win all these championships he
stays at Miami because they're winning
with Drew Brees more than likely so all
these things affect history there's no
question about that Dan but honey for
Tom Brady when you go back and I looked
at his write up because I wrote him up I
talked about in one draft day yeah he
had all the components from a passing
standpoint in a competitive standpoint
he just had to five to four or five to
eight forty which was the slowest forty
time of any quarterback I've ever
written up and the worst vertical at 24
and a half inches of any quarterback I
had written up so again measurables four
quarterbacks mean nothing we know that
Dan and it proved out with Tom Brady
he's a test case for that the best
abscessed ever had five to four or five
to eight and a four 24 and a half
vertical so forget about verticals and
40s for quarterbacks they don't matter
but for Brady he needed to go to a team
that could protect them even anybody
slips into slides in the pocket as well
as anybody but he had the right
situation and I think you could say that
but a lot of quarterbacks Boomer Esiason
going in the second round he was like
disappointed the three first-round picks
went ahead of him when the second round
it worked out well in Cincinnati for him
so again you can't change history but in
some cases the way things fell look
battle and draft day but ultimately were
great for the player who dropped I had a
scout tell me yesterday he's a former
NFL scout and he was watching the show
listening to the show and and I was
talking about the measurables at the
combine and we get caught up in the 40
and I'm not big on the 40 I'd like to
know how quick you are getting to the
hole or pulling guard or if it's a
defensive lineman how quick you're off
the ball like quickness to me is more
important than speed but also he said
the thing that he always looked for he
wanted to know how explosive you are and
he thought the vertical jump was the
most important thing at the combine what
do you make of that I agree I think the
broad jump the vertical jump the three
cones it was quickness and agility and
explosion are the most important part of
it Dan
alvin kamara alvin kamara didn't have a
great 40 time but he had an incredible
broad jump and an incredible vertical
jump so when you look at the numbers if
the numbers are bad across the board he
said wow I got to go back and really
think about it just a great college
player or a good college player with
limited pro potential but if you get a
kid who runs a less-than-stellar 40 but
he has the super numbers and other
explosive as you said athletically
explosive areas then you're fine so I
think that is a very very good way to
look at this thing and 40 times let's
face it then you can get a forty time at
a combine that's disappointing then they
run at the pro day and it's
significantly better
so does that offset the combine yeah
because you're poked you're prodded
you're not up at the right time not
getting the sleep you need you're off
schedule Danny's kids you know how
everybody's kids are creatures of habit
eights they want to do things the same
way every day and when you get them out
of their comfort zone sometimes things
don't go right you never know they could
be a little yeah the time the flu season
who knows what's going on with it but
the pro day can make amends and then you
got to put it all together but I agree
what you said forty times for the for a
lot of these players if you look back
into history and I tried to remind
people that over the weekend when I gave
numbers of players I mean it so neo
Brown Antonio Brown ran four five six
okay we had a 33 and a half vertical I
see a lot of other guys running for
three fives four fours that are
struggling in a liquor out of the league
right now so again you're right that the
40 times for a lot of guys who had
success it wasn't the end-all be-all
do you take a bathroom break during the
first round of the draft I haven't taken
one yet Dan in 36 years at any point in
the first day one day two or day three
of the dress to me the other day because
we were sitting there and they were all
jumping over to the vo they put the show
on ABC land Saturday from 1:00 to 3:00
because it's two hour special and it run
it I use it so Lewis looks over he said
you know about that's not healthy when I
leave the set I lose intensity and
you'll do is kind of focus I just like
to stay there do you like I'm in the
mode when I'm done I'm done you know so
getting up if I don't stick it up I
don't want to get up yeah I thought you
had a stadium power catheter there that
you know now now maybe next year
Hey good to talk to you Mel great to
have you back on we appreciate your time
and thanks for joining us you're the
best that's a milk hyper drive to expert
if you missed any of our interviews this
week from the mercedes-amg man cave go
to the Dan Patrick show app where you
can watch and listen from inside the
mercedes-amg man cave mercedes-amg
driving performance i don't know what
mel thought of this I should have asked
him but when I was doing sports Center
in the mid 90s and we would have a
report from Mel Kiper we would call him
Mel Kiper draft expert and I'd gotten
word that you know you know don't say
that about Mel and I said but he is Mel
Kiper draft expert so it became this
formal title for Mel Kiper and his name
to us was Mel Kiper draft expert as if
Mel Kiper was his first name and draft
expert unless he is last but I loved the
passion and it goes back to what I've
talked about with there are certain
insiders and their passion like Tim
Kirchen no matter what happens in the
game of baseball will tell you something
positive about it
Peter Gammons would always try to tell
you something positive Dickie v like
they're always looking for because it's
their sport or their sports and the same
with Mel Mel has passion it's in it it's
there and that's the first thing that
leaves you passion the energy to want to
do it and Mel still has that after you
know 36 years pretty incredible for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]